two women came in front of Solomon
and each one claimed
that she is the real mother
of that baby
King Solomon started to bring a sword
and to cut the baby cut it into two
parts
one woman was willing
to tear the baby into
but the second woman
refused profusely and insisted
that the baby will stay alive and oh
even today
both sides in this National debate
claim to love the baby
to love our country
I am aware of the increased tension that
is happening between the two parts of
the country
I'm listening to the ones of many
citizens to release this tension but
there is one thing
that I am not willing to accept
there is one
minority that is willing to tear this
country into pieces
it perhaps with violence the ignites
fires
threatens to hurt
politicians in flames
Civil War and calls
for refusal which is a terrible crime
country of Israel cannot
be without the Army and the Army cannot
be with refusal
on the one hand
refused from one side will lead to
refuse from the other side and this will
be the end of our country therefore I
insist insist
the heads of the army and
resources to resist seriously the
refusal not to understand it not to
contain it not to accept it
to stop it
those who call for refusal
those who call for Anarchy and for
violence
are consciously tearing the baby into
pieces
but the majority of the Israeli citizens
on both sides
do not want to tell the baby
they will not tear the people
citizens of Israel
I will not tear this
in both into pieces over the last three
months I've read one I think once again
and I have said that I will turn every
stone in order to find a solution
because I remember
we remember
when we do not stand in front of an
enemy
or stand in front of Brothers
and I say Here and Now
we cannot allow a war between Brothers
we are on a lane or in a collision
course in the Israeli Society
we are
in the height of the crisis that is
threatening our basic unity this crisis
this crisis
insist that all of us must choose
responsibility
yesterday I read belly gunter's letter
in which he
promises to enter into dialogue
with an open mind
I know there are other people who
support this
and to them I open my hand and I do that
after receiving the agreement of most of
my friends
when there is possibilities
to
stop a war between Brothers by dialogue
as prime minister I am taking a timeout
I take a real opportunity
to for real dialogue
we insist on the need to bring the the
necessary reforms to the judicial system
and we will give the opportunity to
achieve them
with with a wide agreement
for such a novel course
and therefore from from a national
responsibility
from and wanted to avoid
deterring the people I I decided to
suspend the second and third reading for
this seating of the parliament
in order to give
to give us an opportunity to reach this
broad agreement
why for the legislation in the next
setting of The
this one or another one way or another
we will bring the balance between
the separation of powers
in order to
strengthen
the right of the individual
I want to address those who support the
National camp we have the majority to do
it we have a big majority huge majority
tens of thousands of our supporters came
to Jerusalem today in order to support
the reforms in order to say
we need a change we need reforms
I want to tell you
I'm proud of you
you are not secondary citizens
I appreciate
that you came out to the streets today
the streets of our capital city in order
to make your Democratic voice heard our
Democratic yoga Democratic voice will
never be silenced and I have to say one
more thing you came spontaneously not
organized not funded
without the
with full of heart and full of sound
you moved me
I asked you just one thing
continue to behave responsibly
and don't get Dragged In to end
provocations
our way is the right way
we have there is a big majority in the
people that knows that we need to have
reforms in the judicial system we will
not let
to take away from the people their free
choice we will not give up
on the way for which we will
elected but we will try
to get to find a broad agreement
citizens of Israel
will live in generation of
building the history has given us a
unique opportunity an opportunity that
never happened to anyone to come back to
our country
to build our homeland
and our country
soon we will celebrate the Passover
the days of Memorial and the day of
independence
we will celebrate together the holidays
we will mourn our fallen together
we will celebrate our independence
together
and we will appreciate it together
the men and women of security
that haven't forgot for one moment okay
duty to protect all of us all the time
all of us
have a common Destiny we all have a
common
destination and this this termination is
to promise
the
thank you